the latest technology that's what people
expect at the Zeman's booth 120,000
visitors are expected to stop by here
it's the biggest stand at the trade fair
it got started just under three weeks
ago with steel wood and plaster bandage
toss is checking out the construction
work is coming along he designed the
stand together with the berlin-based
triode agency the architect knows every
bit of the plan 3,500 square meters and
he sees every mistake Wow yeah come on
gotta hear there's a light in the wrong
place yes I do decide to tell the
colleague exactly what has to be done I
have to be unscrewed and moved to
illuminate a different area so beaten by
this pesky devolvement economy the noise
and Anna chef de Valence tommo sihina of
insulating a hot corner wallet and
Kostas like calamari if this were really
a hardcore mistake it could easily cost
ten thousand euros calculating the delay
involved is much more complicated than
those 10,000 euros the core of the stand
is finally finished it's a model of a
production line to illustrate the
computerization of traditional
industries Zeman's is using industry
four-point-oh to promote new industrial
facilities where machines communicate
with each other as the robots talk with
each other their words should appear
verbatim on screen
this so-called future forum will be
ready in another ten days just a few
hours before the opening there is a
dress rehearsal here is tight
the main act at the stand is supposed to
come from the year 2050 he's here to
prove how advanced Zeman's already is
the idea came from Strauss and his
colleagues they've also written Titan
script
the assembly line is also undergoing a
test run but what the robots do and say
isn't in sync on the screens yet bodies
Paseo a nice basket this year the media
displays are especially elaborate and
prone to error Strauss lets his
colleague know he has some reprogramming
to do then the Siemens bosses arrive
including the CEO to give everything the
final thumbs up
they have to be convinced that Titan is
going to attract a lot of visitors
in the asked moments at first we sat in
the room and thought they really can't
be pitching this to us it's neither a
Zeman's product nor does it have
anything to do with our technologies but
at second glance we saw what a great
opportunity it was inshallah number even
connect make your shots of evanston they
also check the text on the screams they
want one word replaced by Dan Shulman
Quinn design flexibility Daniel Charles
negotiates with them it may just be one
word but it means two hours of work
there's no time for another test run
could be more flexible pesca now this is
an infection will be more flexibility
cooperated yes my invoice yes it's just
one word but whether it will still work
the same way as just theoretical the
trigger points might be different no
idea changing something is always risky
Simone easy call him on the spot Titan
is definitely a hit the storm of
reporters proves that Daniel Strauss was
right to include the robot yes that's
good to have him at least somebody here
speaks perfectly